hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
final trailer for Aquaman before we do
that I wanted to say thank you to all
who balls on patreon it's going great
over there over there we do weekly Q&A
and TV show reactions for many of shows
that includes attack on Titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood also Gotham dressed like a
bet Riverdale and supernatural John also
does music video coverage and breathes
heavily through his nose right now you
know we're getting ready to take that
plunge underwater enjoying it I can
anyway
let's watch this trailer badass
[Music]
[Music]
look at him go by the protector of the
deep
Wow it's right in battle
well we cool
[Music]
now something more
some awesome music yeah
[Music]
never get tired of that last shot when I
got from that trail there was that
awesome Japanese look that Willem Dafoe
has as his new e Deus vult Co he's the
last white samurai Aquaman this plot is
getting more and more clear as it keeps
going and feeling less like mumbo-jumbo
I can never really neither via cohesive
plot I was just like the scenes are so
many moving parts here to this storyline
but now it's all even coming together
even clearer as for what the direction
is and all this focus on the Trident
sand they're the most powerful try that
he can get in order to conquer and when
there's elements in this trail that
haven't been teased in the other
trailers from the mentorship how Willem
Dafoe will actually play a big part in
this all the deals with the Trident
it's like Prime Minister I'm never gonna
be cooler than they are this year yeah
man it's a Thor hammer as his treasure
this movie already looked huge and
somehow this trailer made it look even
more huge and I feel like they probably
have a lot more fiction it's done to
choose from now because some of these
really sweeping scenes through Atlantis
and some of these even earth scenes you
know just look so much bigger than sand
look very epic not just like Hollywood
CG but like some of it's actually there
like we see on that behind the scenes
teaser like this looks almost like a
Lord of the Rings scale version of a
superhero true I mean it kind of feels
like what people do would space yeah in
cinema yeah they've taken to the water
yeah that's been they said in that BTS
thing was like you know this is our
space you know it feels that way it does
especially with all the insane amount of
creature feature designs you have going
on here the the variety of battle
sequences you have not just hand-to-hand
but they even have like they're
underwater ship battles that they had
going on some of the different yeah
giant sea creatures this looks like a
movie that might start you know kind of
small and gets you yeah
by the end and I'm excited to see that
build-up because I feel like no matter
what there's never been anything
like this and every time I see the
trailers and the theaters I get so
excited I have ridiculous amounts of
faith that this is gonna be one
entertaining thrill ride yeah even for
the parts that might not hit I don't
know what will or well there happens to
be parts that don't hit or like cheesy
yeah I feel like the cheese will be fine
yeah because of everything that it going
for here you know I always get this like
pervert vibe from will enjoy why like
see playing a mentor a good guy is like
okay for some reason I heard he was in
it I just assumed he was a bad guy and
then I see him here like okay I'm sure
it'll be lovable ones in some capacity
deeming himself from the Goblin days he
wants to be and I also like that we got
a bit more of a glimpse into some of the
stylistic stuff underwater like you have
some of these sounds that are
manipulated to sound like they're
underwater and the different ways
they're gonna bridge that gap you know
they have some of these scenes that look
like they have creative lighting but
they're not you know obviously in water
shooting it you know and that's some of
the big questions about this movie is
how are they going to make life in
Atlantis come across yeah and I feel
like this is the most we've gotten to
that yet and even though he is Aquaman
already he is already the Arthur curry
you has all these skills that are
developed I mean it's very obvious we're
also gonna get flashbacks to his origin
tale with his mom I think it's gonna be
one of those things where you know she's
like reading a story and maybe he just
thought it was some bedtime story like
at first when he was growing up hey you
know then he realizes it's about you
know yeah that was even sweet just to
have that thing at the beginning where
she's actually being a mom with him and
getting like a funny voice and doing the
whole thing about these got to care
about her when she dies man exactly to
kick those got to be that personal
motivation to come in and then he gets
to fight the crab from wanna dance music
I've always thought Trident were so
goofy and this is the first time where
I'm like try it it's gonna be bitchin
it's been a long time since the Trident
is even had a place and it's like it
hasn't been since gladiator battles that
we've really needed to
so they're just kind of like a frivolous
or like archaic tool but now you know I
think aqua the same way Katniss brought
back bow and arrow I think everybody's
gonna be lowered the throat right there
were horses and a man on fire and I
killed a guy with a trident really the
only goofy parts to this to me look like
when he's a little kid yeah other than
that I'm like I'll take the rest of the
film seriously but the little kid stuff
just looks really silly that's stuff
that I always get the point an appeal of
and you know it's like if you're a kid
I'm sure it's awesome but yeah I'm
always a little bit like I can tell that
you design it or you just kind of
plopped a kid in here yes I guess I'm
wondering to who the main villain will
be because you know you got black man
out here you have armed well over the
folk turn you never know yeah this is
like a war movie that's happening it
seems like or will probably be the
primary antagonist because James Bond's
in love with Patrick Wilson my
prediction in terms of structure how
this might unfold because the way they
were cutting the trailer together in
terms of like you know he jumps in the
water then it's actually transitions
into and he's a kid underwater or when
he catches this the Trident or the spear
or something whatever
oh he catches a try then I think from
Dafoe and then like a spear from
somebody else yeah the way they're
cutting it back and forth so I feel like
the first half or like act 1 all the way
into the first half of Act two will
probably be the sequences we're coming
to the flashbacks and the midpoint is
when he you know meets back up with
volcko who's talking about the trident
in everyday life they're saying that up
like that's the beginning of act 2 but I
don't think it is
now the midpoint is when they start
talking about the Trident they're gonna
do like a Deadpool kind of thing we're
like every time a major thing from the
past pops up then we're gonna get a
flashbacks it's like you catch that
sword and we're gonna see how he learns
well that's the whole movies gonna slow
down I mean this is my prediction on
like the structure uh just makes sense
to me if it were to unfold that way of
course I got a bunch of other scenes in
between him media but Mirra them going
to figure out a lot of this out I think
this is gonna be one awesome awesome
time yeah what if he's gonna be a [ __ ]
in time that upsets someone that I kept
saying that at another video really
apparently I can't use my own language I
can't say bitchin dude trying to sound
cool bitching is a classic yeah hey what
you film looks tight this film looks
chill man
af this is just radical year dude hello
there fellow children the other thing
too is like this it kind of makes me
think of the DC EU it's a slightly
different way it almost gives it two
halves now cuz it's like you have
another this kind of reminded me of the
feelings I got watching the Wonder Woman
trailer in a way because my mascara and
water cuz the mascara and water
you know like beaches and shores and
flips at me partly but but that blend of
like here's kind of a mystical world
that feels a bit more realized than a
lot of the stuff in the Snider's in the
Snyder flicks basically yeah seems very
tangible and that's exciting you don't
need to hate Zack Snyder's John I loved
Zack so my and Michael Bay and Michael
Bay and Eli Roth and I hope that one day
they all get together and they make a
superhero film together because our
grades that gonna be you're gonna have
it be like darn cool with why a lot of
poop humor and then who's the third guy
alright guys well thanks for watching
with us Aquaman
did you get your tickets oh [ __ ] tickets
reputation belt and check us on patreon
TV show reactions q and A's would love
to have you become a patron eject to die